Sigourney Weaver is one of the most
esteemed actors working today and for
her latest role she's playing a blue
Teenage alien who's 59 years younger
than her in creating the Technicolor
eye-popping world of Pandora James
Cameron looked to a different sort of
space epic in an interview with variety
he said if you look at how George Lucas
did it in the universe that he created
he chose to make each different biome
each different culture have their own
planets around the Galaxy and I thought
while that's not the way earth works I
can spend as many films as I want to
make just on Pandora just by going to
different places Cameron has begun to
lift the curtain on Pandora's cultural
and biospheric diversity and Avatar the
way of water with so many new Shores to
explore it stands to reason that the way
of water carries a few unanswered
questions what is the fate of the forest
dwelling omatakaya people what will
happen to the Tolkien why did James
Cameron cast the septuagenarian to play
a 14 year old well apparently that last
question has been a particular point of
contention among Avatar fans Sigourney
Weaver made her first trip to Pandora in
2009's Avatar in which she played
exobiologist Dr Grace Augustine
[Music]
even though her character was killed
Weaver nabbed an unlikely role in avatar
The Way of water as Kiri the 14 year old
adopted daughter of Jake and natiri Kiri
is one of the most important new
characters in The Avatar Universe the
daughter of Dr Augustine Kiri boasts a
unique connection to the environment in
AWA still for some fans cast in a now 73
year old actress as a teenager was a
bridge too far one Twitter user wrote it
really didn't work at all the movie is
great but it was so jarring some thought
that the unconventional casting Choice
was a missed opportunity to lean into
the themes of reincarnation one person
said Sigourney Weaver playing Kiri was
an interesting idea and could lead to
Some solid World building with
reincarnation in the world tree and the
like but the performance I don't know I
could really see this was an adult
trying to play a child others felt that
Weaver's performance felt naturally less
youthful when sharing scenes with her
younger castmates leading her to stick
out like a sore thumb while teenage
Sigourney Weaver took some viewers out
of the action others were deeply in
impressed by the actress's commitment to
the role one redditor asked is it wrong
for me to want to see more young
Sigourney Weaver movies she was awesome
and killed it here one fan viewed
Cameron's casting Choice as a win for
older actors especially women who were
frequently overlooked they wrote I
Honestly Love James Cameron for this
we've accepted way too much ages about
Hollywood Weaver's performance also won
over some critics for consequence Liz
Shannon Miller wrote Weaver's
performance actually proves to be one of
the film's high points it's one of those
damn what can't she do moments watching
her embody the character ultimately
Weaver's greatest champion is James
Cameron himself the director told Empire
Sigourney just became younger she looked
younger she had more energy and she
never quite stepped out of Kiri for our
whole capture period She had a glow on
her face and lightness in her step and a
fun spirit